the clock works well when it's part
thick together similarly our life and
reality consists of many parts and we
would like to see how the different
parts tick together
therefore Eurostar produces a number of
indicators that help shed light on how
our economy society and environment
interact let's have a look at a few
examples of these interactions in spite
of the recent economic crisis gross
domestic product per capita in the EU
overall has increased by 13 points two
percent between 2000 and 2014 and over
the same period the employment rate has
gone up reaching 69 point 2 percent
higher employment helps to reduce a
number of people at risk of poverty and
social exclusion in 2013 there were
about 123 million people in such a
situation in the EU about a million
fewer than the previous year education
can play a crucial role in increasing
employment and reducing poverty the
number of early leavers from education
and training has fallen continuously
since 2000 to reach 11 point one percent
in 2014 at the same time the number of
people aged between 30 and 34 with
tertiary education has constantly
increased reaching 37 point nine percent
in 2014 investing in knowledge and
education can help to make our world
more environment-friendly
the EU has marked its achievements here
having reduced greenhouse gas emissions
by almost 18% since 1990 and nearly
doubling the use of renewable energy in
the past
years overall energy consumption has
also decreased from its peak in 2006
smart usage of our natural resources is
key to achieving a growing and then
fireman friendly economy resource
productivity which matches the
relationship between gross domestic
product and domestic materials
consumption has improved in the EU by
26% since 2005 it really looks like a
ticking clock doesn't it our modern
societies are made up of a multitude of
factors dynamics and relations Eurostat
helps us to understand the world around
us through the set of indicators which
people find important to measure the
indicators you saw provide just a few
examples of how statistics capture the
connections between different spheres of
our lives if you want to discover more
just go to our website and open our
publications
you